this is a picnic sandwich with a Twist
but the secret is in the layers
I'm gonna make a delicious tapana a
puree of Olives seasoned with capers and
anchovies
a nice tablespoon of extra virgin olive
oil
garlic in
a little teaspoon of red wine vinegar
that just sort of zaps up the flavor
I quite like leaving it nice and chunky
tastes better and feels richer I much
prefer spreading a smooth layer of
tapenade rather than using butter
now to prepare my first Mediterranean
sandwich filling I want nice long slices
of courgette because yes can be a bland
vegetable season them nicely once that
Grill is nice and hot a tablespoon of
olive oil
the more color you put on those
courgettes the more flavor
while my griddle courgette is cool I can
prepare the bread this is a stunning
beautiful country loaf but we're not
going to slice it I'm just going to cut
the top off because I'm sending a picnic
sandwich basket
and then an inch from the crust and go
around
scoop out a nice Large Hollow don't
waste this bread put that out it's dry
it makes the most amazing bread crumbs
the secret now is filling that cavity
with all those wonderful Mediterranean
flavors I'm going to leave them to sort
of Sip and marinate lightly season the
inside of the loaf
drizzle out of olive oil
line for that wonderful tapenade and
spread it generously
puts the groundwork in starts to set the
tone to the flavors that we're
incorporating
traditionally the main protein in pan
Banya would be tuna I'm sticking with
the med but replacing the fish with some
of my family's Italian favorites
Parma ham and start lining my sandwich
from the center
every time I add another ingredient it's
just another stunning layer of texture
and flavor but what I'm thinking about
is what actually complements
the next layer mozzarella a little spoon
of my tapenade we've got the most
amazing Aquila pepper so we've got a
nice Smoky Barbecue flavor open them up
and lay them
on top next layer is wonderful grilled
courgettes
on top of that some blush tomatoes
concentrated but really chewy and
delicious and each time lightly press
them down
creamy mozzarella again
and finally peppers
push that down not too firm
fold in
and seal that with your tapenade
almost like a little glue now lid on
to seal all that flavor in there
and not only travels well but actually
tastes delicious
that is one stunning
picnic sandwich
[Music]
just when you're guessing that you're
cutting up a delicious country loaf
[Music]
look at that baby wow and who would not
want to join you
on a picnic with a sandwich like that
My ultimate picnic lunch to surprise and
impress pan Banya bursting with Rich
Sunshine flavors and served with a
refreshingly zingy carrot cumin and
orange salad
[Music]
for me the most important part of the
Caesar salad is that dressing
Rich creamy slightly spicy
Begin by making a basic mayonnaise
start off with the egg yolks in just
a little spoon Dijon and then a little
splash of red wine vinegar
start whisking
once you've got that nice slightly
thickened texture
drizzle in your olive oil
fall through
your whisk it's like a nice thick
double cream texture
beautiful
now take the Mayo to another level with
Anchovies and crushed garlic now chop up
the anchovies and the garlic together
so I almost want that to be like a
really nice
puree then grated Parmesan lemon juice
that will make the dressing
citrusy
lighter in color and then a little
splash of water
and
now
all of a sudden it transforms that
mayonnaise into an amazing
delicious
light dressing
nice
job the croutons and I like using crusty
bread for extra Crunch and just dice up
your bread season with salt and pepper
then add to a hot pan with olive oil and
Fry give that a really nice toss as the
croutons start to turn golden simply
great on a generous amount of Parmesan
cheese keep them rolling around stop
them from sticking together look at that
really nice cheesy delicious
Crouton and now
they're out
now for the fun job assembling the
Caesar salad starting with Romaine
lettuce
and don't slice the lettuce
too thinly
a squeeze of lemon on with half of that
gutsy anchovy Mayo dressing
saving some to coat your chicken later
then sprinkle half your croutons
add the remaining croutons and finish
with a good grating of Parmesan cheese
that for me is a perfect season salad
however I'm going to take it to another
level and grill a stunning chicken
breast start by preheating your griddle
pan then butterfly your chicken breast
simply slice from the thin end towards
the thick bit of the breast put the
knife to the work and literally just
open up
now that's how we butterfly a chicken
breast so therefore it will cook twice
as quick and just nice and moist in the
center
[Music]
the chicken on both sides with salt and
ground pepper lay your chicken breast
onto the grill
[Music]
never oil the grill and do it absolutely
ready to cook your chicken now
turn them over
[Music]
useful
cook for three to four minutes on each
side until the chicken's got those
lovely Stripes from The Griddle which
adds a gorgeous Smoky flavor whilst they
rest spoon over some of the remaining
anchovy dressing
the chicken cools down the flavor the
seasoning of the anchovy the garlic and
the parmesan seeps into that chicken
slice the chicken into strips
hmm
wow I serve the chicken warm in a
separate Bowl so it doesn't Wilt the
salad spoon the dressing
finished out with a little touch of
dressing
an American classic
I think one of the most popular sellers
anywhere in the world but it's still the
most delicious